and airline passengers who are able to
beat the weather this Thanksgiving might
find themselves wondering just how small
is too small when it comes to airplane
seats the FAA hopes to have an answer to
that soon it started test aimed at
setting a minimum standard for seat size
and the space between rows Kris Van
Cleave visited the test facility and
joins us from Reagan National Airport
outside Washington Chris what did you
learn well good morning
this took an order from Congress to get
the FAA to do this testing it's the
first time they've looked at seat size
specifically some perspective here this
piece of paper is actually bigger than
some of the seats people will be getting
into today as they take to the skies and
this grows out of concern as seats have
gotten smaller space has gotten tighter
and more people have gotten on to fuller
airplanes that that could impact how
long it takes to safely get off a plane
in an emergency in a simulated cabin
that can be filled with smoke and
plunged into darkness the FAA will try
to determine at what point the size of
seats and space between rows becomes a
hazard to evacuating an airplane quickly
is there an ideal amount of time to get
everybody off an airplane as quick as
possible
if there is an emergency Stacy Zinke
McKee is with the FAA the cueing is
usually not for people to get into the
aisles but actually to get out of the
aircraft fliers might think their seats
are too close but that may not have any
impact on safety at all correct it might
not but that's the reason we're going to
gather data when American Airlines
flight 383 had an engine catch fire on
takeoff in Chicago it took more than two
minutes to evacuate now
in part because passengers grab their
luggage but during the 12 days of FAA
testing at this Oklahoma City facility
the 720 volunteer passengers won't have
to deal with real-life obstacles like
bags smoke comfort animals or the dark
and the volunteers will be broken into
groups of just 60 the smallest 737 seats
at least double that the FAA says it
designed the test to focus solely on two
variables seat width and the space
between rows known as seat pitch these
tests are gonna be nothing but a sham
John Brio is from the National consume
leak it and nine other groups sent a
letter to Transportation Secretary
Elaine Chao and the FAA Administrator
criticizing the seat testing consumers
should not think for a minute that these
tests are being done in a way that would
accurately represent what could happen
in an emergency evacuation Braille
worries airlines will use the FAA s
findings to further reduce space and add
more seats airline seat width is down as
much as four inches over the last 30
years to as little as just 16 inches
wide and seat pitch has shrunk from
about 35 inches to 31 and in some cases
as little as 28 inches let's take a look
but Spirit Airlines says we're looking
at seat size all wrong it's more about
the amount of usable space next month
they're launching redesigned memory foam
seats with a curved back for better
legroom at 28 inches apart but CEO Ted
Christie says you'll have as much room
as seats with 30 inches of pitch do you
have any concerns about this not being
enough space to safely evacuate a plane
quickly for people to be comfortable
none at all
you know there's been many tests done to
ensure that these seats and our
configuration meets with safety
requirements while they are closer
together than a first-class product
they've been validated to show that
there's there's adequate space to egress
the airplane and in fairness the spirit
those seats are noticeably more
comfortable than the ones they're
replacing the FAA testing should be
complete by the end of the year with a
report coming next summer from there it
goes to an advisory committee that will
make recommendations to the FAA about
regulations
so bottom line any new rules are
probably years away Anthony Chris thank
you very much one word Chris wider
please wider
I bet first-class hasn't changed that
much I mean the size of those seeds is
it's crazy